They found that students who were not asked to list their race performed well,
and as for the students who were asked to list their race they found that
African American students became really anxious and performed poorly on their
test. This is what we meant earlier about stereo types possibly perpetuating
themselves, here we see that stereotypes can influence an individual to behave
in a way that confirms the stereotype. So why is this important? Well, think of
a stereotype such as girls don't do well in math or science. Or men aren't
emotionally aware. If you're in one of these categories, for example a girl,
and you're aware of the stereotype it can actually influence your overall
performance. This is quite fascinating and important to be aware of because the
stereotype girls are not good at math might prevent girls from going into a
field that's heavy in math or even may cause individual girls to perform poorly
on a math exams. Can you think of any stereotype groups that you may belong to?
And how this could possibly affect your performance on different tasks? This is
a great topic for the discussion forums. However, it's a sensitive topic so
please be respectful. Now, let's go to Susan who has an example for us.